coming up next I just feel like things
have changed and like now you'll see
like 10 year old kids who are like like
they'll just see these like only fans
models or whatever like and it's just so
like they don't even blink did I always
hear women say that like they care so
much about beauty standards but it's
like if you cared about beauty standards
and why aren't you 120 pounds I would
say another problem would be a lot of
females are emotionally unstable who has
harder beauty standards to meet men or
women women
also when women only swipe right five
percent of the time on dating apps and
they also find 80 of men is unattractive
I don't know I just don't think that
they're that we really like look too
deep into men's appearance that much I
think by not having the option for
abortion generally speaking say 99 of
the time
um I think women would just sort of wise
up
okay what percent of Western women are
marriage material in 2023
that's a really hard question
that came into my head maybe 25 25
percent
um probably 20 20 percent
was the question what percentage of
women are why football marriage material
marriage material
um
yeah under 20 under 20. what do you
think
um I'd say 30 30 percent let's see about
15 percent
the way how things are going right now
is the last time breed so that's 20
percent
10 percent
do you think women are better off in
2023 than they were in 1953
and tell me why yes or no and why
I don't think so I think this is just my
personal opinion
in 2023
you are better off materialistically
um that's just the way Society is we
have to sort of fend for ourselves so um
you know if I really wanted to I can
work out hard I can go out by Mercedes
get Chanel bag whatever but
you know
I still have to walk down the street
alone at night not knowing
what could happen you know and and like
you know the option to sit at home and
be a housewife isn't readily available
to me so I do believe that women in the
1950s were better off
just because life was simpler also like
technology wasn't around back then and I
think that
especially social media is the most
toxic thing to happen to us you know
we're we're more connected than ever
before but I think kind of what you were
saying like spiritually we're further
apart than we ever have been because
social media and and everything it's
just a front and you get to tailor that
front how you want to be perceived
um so yeah I definitely think that well
me personally I would have much
preferred to have been around in the
1950s
yeah I agree I definitely would have
much preferred to be around in that time
because you know things were just I
would say more
simple back then and just more
just I wouldn't say easier but just
there wasn't a lot of pressure you know
you you didn't have that much pressure
to prove yourself or you weren't
comparing yourself to people all the
time and you know you kind of just did
what you did to get by and you know
communities were stronger you looked
after your family and you know you
weren't distracted by social media and
you know what people were doing and what
people are wearing and buying nowadays
so I feel like we we have been like
brainwashed in a way and I would much
prefer to be back in those days to be
honest
um I would say
um obviously we talk about gender right
now but
um for race
um I think in 1953 like it must have
been way harder for like black couples
to um
be able to even like function
um so and then 2023 um we're much more
aware by like race and like
um the effects that like black people
have like so for me to find a lovely
black man in 2023 I feel like
yeah it will be much easier for us to
actually be in an open relationship
um
no not open over because no I want to be
in a monogamous relationship but yeah
it's what do you know to even hold hands
down the street without yeah so yeah I
think 2023
can you ask the question again
are women better off in 2023 than they
were in 1953 oh no I think like they've
really influenced by society and that
they're like chasing what Society is
feeding them
and like
when they actually get there they're so
unhappy because they've realized they've
wasted their life chasing something that
was designed to destroy them
I think that was always implicated from
the 1950s even till now it's always been
fashion there's always been up our
middle and lower class so people have
always been chasing somethings you know
I mean to Bear themselves so me
personally I'd say
it's just more in your face because
we've got access to it you know I mean
certain people that what we're now
looking at and thinking oh wow they've
got this and that there's always been an
upper class middle class and a lower
class it's just more in your face now
and we more look at it like oh if they
can do it I must be able to do it it's
just you're chasing it quicker because
it's in your face but in
aspect of like fashion and everything
nothing has really changed I'll be
honest it's just more in your face it's
just more accessible but for me
personally I'm happy in 2023 I think
social media makes women more delusional
yeah it does but it's in your face
that's right it's like they start
thinking they look like the filters
I hate after Rochelle someone messaged
me off of Instagram I'll look at it I'm
like what the who was that 100 it's like
they start to literally think that
they're the filters and that the
attention they get from those filters is
equates to real life and it doesn't but
that just as human beings we've always
looked up like there's always been kings
and queens you know I mean like so it's
just more in your face it weren't
accessible like that like the rich used
to be around a rich the poor used to be
around the poor do you know what I mean
and if you did see rich person or you'd
look up to being that person but it's
exactly the same I'd say it's just more
in your face it's more accessible I
think that's what creators are designed
to do like the economy now relies on the
computer which influences the outcome of
society as a whole I actually think
women are better off today because they
have no consequences for bad decisions I
don't think it makes us happy but I just
think like before if you left your man
you were homeless now we have all these
programs to bail us out of every bad
decision that we made so if you look at
it very true I mean I don't think it
makes us happy just like it's kind of
like if you give a kid everything they
want are they really going to be happy
at 18. I almost think women are spoiled
in 2022 yeah 23. oh my gosh that's
afternoon
I forgot you agree disagree yeah yeah
you don't think women are spoiled in
2023 no idea you don't oh no I think
every they're super reasonable oh okay
that's how this is pretty reasonable
panel but I think it you know you said
obviously like are women better off yeah
I think I think yeah yeah I think I
agree they are like better off yeah
um my answer was more coming from like a
personal point of view of what I'd like
and you're right it's about what what
would make us happy but if you're
actually looking at it black and white
yeah you're better off like if even if
you do go homeless or whatever like
starting early fans like we have that
option now or or something yeah if you
get pregnant that you still shop if you
get pregnant they used to have shotgun
shotgun weddings now they just have
abortions wow it's true yeah it is you
know 40 of women that have had abortions
over two or more
what are they going to have in the
future so it's literally a form of birth
control in 2023. yeah people use
abortions as birth control and it's it's
not great
I don't think it's great but I
definitely think we're better off in
2023 I don't think we would have been
able to do this in the 1950s sit with a
woman-only panel and discuss topics so
I'm grateful that we're here they had
some actually I've been reacting to some
yeah it's like um there was uh but were
they like as opinion as a view yeah it
was it was well probably not as well I
mean I can't imagine they had the views
YouTube that's how it is but I was
watching this debate I don't know if we
do we post the reaction of the debate of
the housewife versus the
you remember it was like a housewife
versus a career woman and it was so
interesting because it was the same
conversation we're having today but it
was literally it might have been the 60s
or like 50s 60s time frame but then
maybe it wouldn't be as diverse
Maybe I'm probably not probably not so
like I'm I think we're better off now in
2023 yeah we've got more access to more
things but it's like I think we're
better off but we're not happier or
something yeah like I don't think women
the outcomes like leave us happy and I
feel like what you said um social media
the delusion I feel like a lot of us
well I speak for myself maybe we spend
so much time on social media that we get
distracted and we start looking at what
we see and thinking okay this is what we
need this is what we should be doing
this is where we should do and in
reality it's not like that everyone's
showing their highlights nobody's
showing what is really happening yeah
well and I think the delusion is leaving
us single and childless yeah I mean what
who is a kid here who is Kid you have a
kid and they say 50 of women are going
to be single and childless by it's 20 30
so I mean it's half of us
like we look at this room half of us
probably won't have kids a size that's
already sad
but it's so sad I hope it's not anything
but it's it's but does that make people
happy and my grandma you know what's
crazy my grandma
um she she's like pretty sick so I don't
know how much longer she's gonna live
but so I've been asking her like these
like deep questions I'll get them on
video and one of them I said like do you
have any regrets in life and she told me
I wish I had more kids and I said
Grandma you had nine kids
how many did you want she's like 12. wow
but it's like when you ask girls I mean
who here wants nine kids I definitely
wouldn't mind yeah you would have nine
kids 100 really have you had one yet no
but have the one first and then come
back to me I don't even need to have the
one like I've already looked after
children and no I mean child child
laborers
that it's nothing it's worse it's like I
don't know a thousand times worse one of
my body's built for that it is built for
that but I don't know if you would go
nine times for that but it's it's
interesting because the conversation you
guys are having now that's like a modern
conversation because if I said that to
my grandma she would be like yeah no we
have more than nine yeah so it's kind of
it's kind of just it's it's a Testament
of the times definitely yeah I think I I
feel like women really wanna well
there's a lot of people who actually
want to just work so I think they're
thinking that they don't want to have
that many kids just so that they can
still have that freedom and that
flexibility
um and there's a lot of women who
actually don't even want kids as well
and there is a study that said 80 of
women are not children
so the majority of women do want kids I
think it's yeah because if I I've had
girls come on the show and they'll say
oh I don't want kids and then my next
question is well what if it was with
this guy and there's always some say it
because they they're with someone that
doesn't want kids or they just feel like
they can't be your mother or they can't
get the guy they want to have kids with
that's true and so it's almost like a
coat no I don't I don't like I mean some
girls really don't
but it's I don't think it's a large
percentage of women yeah I wonder how
old those women are as well the women
who say that they they don't I'd be
interested to find a woman it's like mid
30s plus it's usually a COPE in my yeah
I actually I want to do a panel with
single childless women over the age of
55. yeah it's hard to recruit for that
though so if the comments want to help
me in London
that's specific of a panel but just to
get their point of view because I feel
like around like 50s women get more
based a little bit where they kind of
are not like you still get the 40 year
old saying oh I'm gonna have three kids
like when
yeah menopause is coming oh dear body
clock
um what is the number one issue facing
women today
not being raised in a two-parent
household
I've had the issues
um safety not being able to walk at
night by myself I'm terrified I'm not
being trained to be a woman or a lady or
mother I have a question about that
night um do you think men can walk home
alone at night no no I speak for them as
well yeah I mean maybe there's an age
bracket the way that London is right now
yeah no definitely not
um but I feel like there's just more
risk when you're a woman I mean
so if I get attacked and a man gets
attacked who's more likely to get help
from other men the women the women yeah
because someone might come across and
not even know who to help if it's two
men but with the woman like I feel like
people will automatically go to yeah
have you seen those videos of the woman
hitting the man and the Man hitting the
wall yeah and it's like they always help
the woman the man they're like good luck
yeah
yeah I don't know personally I just
don't feel safe on the streets
um I get Ubers literally everywhere or
you know someone will pick me up or
I'm terrified to walk alone by myself
just even coming here to tonight I was
terrified
because you get like hollowed out on the
roads and that like hi darling no not
even that I can handle that but I've
actually been followed home like I've
been followed home like you know I've
had someone trying to rob me I've had
someone try and touch me inappropriately
you know and it's it's a lot to deal
with and what area is that sorry to see
um well I'm from east London so wow yeah
just okay I don't know
um anyone else number one issue facing
women
I don't know if it's number one but I do
want to bring it up again I think
promiscuity
is um
tainting us especially like now like you
know you're a similar age to me like
we've been on social media I don't know
about you but like I think I got
Snapchat when I was like 13. yeah so
it's like I know like before you had
like page three and things like that but
like
I just feel like things have changed and
like now you'll see like 10 year old
kids who are like like they'll just see
these like only fans models or whatever
like and it's just so like they don't
even blink like it's just so like
everyone's just used to it even Tick
Tock as well even like Tick Tock you
have like 14 year olds looking like
they're 18 like you know moving their
waist around it's like like it's really
scary I've seen it it's really scary and
I just don't think it's gonna do anyone
any help in the long run men or women
like it's it's tainting everyone's view
of everything in my opinion 100 number
one thing for women right now is body
image yeah yeah definitely body image
whoever is
having your waist your bombing your tits
your lips Botox is definitely body image
weave or whatever like yeah I feel it
for you women because like if you don't
look a certain way you're not doing it
you know what I'm saying women were
worried about body image then why are 60
of women overweight in the UK it's worse
it's worse in America it's like 80
percent
but don't you think I feel like
sometimes um like even if you're
overeating even if you feel like you
want to look a type of way
so even if you feel like you want to
look a type of way like you might just
eat it away yeah gain weight then you
gain weight by eating lunch I guess but
people are emotional eaters
that's true yeah but also I feel like a
lot of women get into relationships or
they get very comfortable and they just
start to put on weight like just
naturally I don't know yeah facts yeah
it's comfortable yeah and I don't know
they call it like relationship weight
um but then you just take it too far and
then you really let yourself go but
you're like I've got to get in the gym
but my point is I was here even say that
like they care so much about beauty
standards but it's like if you cared
about beauty standards then why aren't
you 120 pounds I would say another
problem would be a lot of females are
emotionally unstable
that'll be another issue
to put all of that in a box yeah but
some people when they say they care
about their body image they're not
actually talking about their weight they
might just be talking about here how
their lips look how their eyes look how
so they're not focusing on their body
just think about this bit who has worse
beauty standards men or women
what do you mean like looking for or
yeah who is who is harder beauty
standards to meet men or women oh women
women women
how so when women only swipe right five
percent of the time on dating apps and
they also find 80 of men is unattractive
I think men have it harder because the
chances of a man an individual Man
versus an individual woman of being
found attractive by the majority is a
lot lover for a man so like maybe like
they see the maybe like women we see you
know someone on I don't know like a
magazine or something we think oh I
don't look like her like sure that's a a
body standard that we feel like we have
to live up to but that's just how we
feel that's not the reality the reality
is we don't have to live live up to
anything really the majority of like
girls can find someone to partner up
with them sleep with them whatever it
may be whereas guys sure there might not
be a very obvious in your face you must
look like this but us girls as the judge
of men
um they've got way more to live up to
like the average guy like most of us
probably wouldn't mind I don't really
agree with that I feel like imagine if
only two women in this room were found
attractive by Men by the majority of men
that'd be sad
so how how can you say we have worse
beauty standards
like it's not it's not that it's not
even girls saying they're okay like they
deem 80 of men as unattractive not just
oh he's okay he's kind of he's medium
ugly
I don't think looks are looked at that
much when it comes to men I'll be honest
with you I think women look at status
they look at financial status they look
at where is this man at in his life also
yeah I mean obviously you have to be
attracted to the person that you're
dating but most of the time
personally me and like people that I
know the women in my life they have
never really looked at a guy and gone oh
he's got a really pretty face they're
like he's a man he's a man he's tall
yeah he's gonna be taller than you at
least a woman I've dated men who were
shorter than women and I'm a tall woman
yeah but you're not you're not the
majority and we're talking about women
in general women filter out men under
six foot on dating apps eighty percent
of the time
and the saddest thing is normally like
five foot five and they're taking all
the two men yeah six foot two babies
yeah but people's motives people's
motives on dating apps are also very
questionable and women most of women do
go on there as well and just to get a
bit of an ego boost or have a free meal
whatever like and I I think that would
be true if that's not the number one way
that people were meeting today
um so you know if the outcomes weren't
relationships that's the number one way
then I would agree with you but
I don't know I just don't think that
there that we really like look too deep
into men's appearance that much yes we
like Kai I think we do look at the
height but I don't think we look at oh
is his face perfect oh he's got a double
chin you know women look at stuff like
that we look at things oh my face looks
fat like oh I need to get a nose job we
look at it not men
so it's like it's like how are we gonna
like men don't care yeah but it's this
ideology that men like that typical like
Barbie skinny small waist petite girl
and I guess Society has kind of told us
that and we've sort of believed it and
the media also tell us that as well so
over the years we've just kind of we've
been brainwashed we we think that that's
what we love doing how's that listen to
the ass song in High School
yeah I feel like the skinny trend is
coming in now look at the Kardashians
look at Kylie Jenner she just got rid of
her BBL you know Kim's gone super skinny
yeah but none of them are wives yeah
like yeah they make money but they're
not wives that's true it's not it's like
women are changing for women they're not
even doing it for men if you ask men
what they want they don't want lip
filler they don't want your forehead not
to move they don't want to pound a
makeup they just want like natural light
okay can I ask you can I can I ask you a
question okay I hear hear what you're
saying but answer me this if they don't
want the girls with the lip fillers and
the big balms and the skinny little
waist why is it when you go down a guy
is following on Instagram every single
girl he is following looks like that oh
do men look at Instagram for wives candy
[Music]
no it's no good for them they all want a
piece of it it's like if you look at
their corn Star Search is it is it going
to be the wife material okay they don't
want to imagine but if they're looking
at people if they're looking at women
like that then they
somewhat find those women attractive no
yeah for the night yeah Candy's like
sweets I always say it's like sweets
because it is like you know it's no good
for you but you just want to really but
isn't that scary for when you get into a
relationship and you think oh he's going
to cheat them if he doesn't want a piece
of it and it's that good it depends what
kind of man you're going I don't know
people are so fussy about picking him
men just have a lower attraction floor
than us yeah so it's kind of like for
I've had guys explain this where they're
like if you're just above their like
minimum dating floor it's kind of all
the same to them I mean obviously
there's some girl like the hotter you
are the more you get away with in a way
that's what they say they're kind of
like the Richer they are for a lot of
women the more they get away with in a
way but no matter not nearly as picky
they're kind of like enough
we're more judgmental to ourselves than
how men are judgmental to us
yeah I don't know
it's interesting too I'll have guys like
rate girls one to ten just to like see
and they're always like very generous in
my like guys they just they're looking
for a reason to to qualify a girl not to
disqualify like we are yeah
okay
trust him
[Music]
um
are abortion rights needed to create a
truly equal Society no
can you explain it a bit further like
what do you mean by abortion rights the
right to an abortion you guys have it
here up to six months but in the US we
don't it's an American channel so yeah
so our abortion rights needed to create
a truly equal Society
I don't even understand the question
yeah of course yeah
should abortion be allowed oh yeah you
shouldn't have a choice what of course I
am I think abortion should be illegal
and however I do obviously we have
common law in this country I do think
that there should be some kind of uh you
know common law
um where under specific circumstances
you might qualify for one but I think
the general standard
um legislation should be that it's
illegal and then under certain
circumstances or situations which like I
think they're pretty obvious we all know
um then it should be allowed and also
like if it's um you know if the child is
is gonna be born like disabled or
something I I do agree that maybe you
should be able to decide if if you want
to I don't know that's a really
difficult one I'm not gonna get into
that because I don't actually know how I
feel about that but generally I don't
really believe in abortion at all really
what about you
no I I would like to have that option I
would definitely like to have that
option
um things happen in life and you know I
might fall pregnant and I'm have you
fall pregnant
well I don't know things happen by not
being careful
I I fall pregnant takes all the
accountability off of you yeah but if I
become pregnant yeah but if I become my
choice and God forbid my husband lost
his job and you know we're not really
great financially whatever the
circumstances are and we are not fit to
raise children of course I want an
abortion and I should be allowed to do
that are you typically with men that
don't have jobs and can't raise children
I hope not but we never know what will
happen in life you know so you you gotta
have I would like to know that I have
that option but you have the action of
contraception so why not pick that
option first and think preventatively
instead of um reactionally yeah
a caution not always 100 so I agree
things happen no that's 99.5 effective
if you get an IUD I had the
contraception pill and I got a child it
didn't work for me
like did you get the IUD and wear a
condom too I didn't I don't like I
wouldn't ever consider that with my
partner but I had the conceptive pill
and it didn't work and it's 99.9
effective which one did you take
um what's it called the morning after
bar yeah was it the five day or the
three day one
um so long ago I don't really know but
it didn't work you took the morning
after pill yeah
I did that's like the last case result I
don't take contraception so like I did
take the morning after Bill and it did
work yeah but that's a choice to not be
on birth control yeah I don't I'm not on
birth control which is why I said I
agree with you I believe that you should
have the option but I think the options
that you choose in terms of not keeping
a child
I think you have to I believe that you
should be able to justify them like if
she's not meant if a woman feels she's
not mentally stable to have the child or
for all the right reasons I think if
you've got options to do everything else
then I do believe you should have that
option that's my opinion up to up to how
many months oh no no I don't like it has
to happen immediately if you do if it's
like you've got a bump and I don't agree
with that I think that's wrong
so here it's up to six months do you
agree no no no no no it's too far when
do you agree with it immediately like
three months no that's too far I think
that's okay
immediately like as soon as you know if
you believe that you don't want a child
you've got to act really quick and I
believe that a woman's body is a bit
messy because so you might still be
bleeding you know what I mean anything
past like seven eight weeks and I I
don't I don't know just don't think
that's right yeah a lot of people don't
even find out until like after two
months I know a couple people that
they're like three months and they're
like this is your last day to choose
somebody asked me to take them to a
clinic in London when because I'm from
Birmingham when she was like six months
and I would wouldn't do that couldn't do
that hmm
that's a full-grown baby yeah I
understand it's got a heartbeat as soon
as you're pregnant but that's a full
grown child
you've had long enough to decide and you
understand like people are completely
against it I respect that but I just
don't I think the woman should have a
choice how do you not know for two
months
some people don't
know some people don't know
to me it's just being bailed out for a
bad decision it's just weird like at the
end of the day take birth control or
don't have sex
I don't sleep with or don't sleep with
people that wouldn't be good Fathers or
if you're not financially safe stable
yeah okay if that's not as simple people
not having a baby but that's not easy I
don't think it's an excuse that people
have one night stands and I don't even
think that we should be saying like oh
people have one night stands to [__]
like it doesn't have to be a one night
stand that's the way you get pregnant
though like it just happens and you
could actually happen you could actually
be in a committed relationship and then
an abortion whatever reason it could
happen that way but you can make choices
so it doesn't happen
but it doesn't change the fact that it
does happen but my whole thing is it's a
bailout for poor decisions because at
the end of the day if you get pregnant
you made a poor decision
if you didn't want to be pregnant yeah
there'll be a lot more illegal abortions
though like people will be going to like
back corners and I think it's better to
do it the proper way well obviously
there's no proper way to think but like
the proper way is surgically everything
then to go to back Corners down
abortions are performed oh yeah they're
really nice
they pull off the limbs one by one so
they pull off the leg then they pull off
the next leg then they pull off the arm
and the other arm then they they crush
the skull and vacuum it out is that is
that true yeah that's true that's how
many months are like five six months you
can have that done like as soon as it's
gotten the other way the other way it
starves the kid and it like falls out
and I had a girl on the show explaining
her abortion at like two three months
and she said she was shocked by how
informed it was because it had like a
full head a whole I think she said it I
can't remember the exact stuff she said
but she said she was shot because a lot
of the pictures like they don't really
inform you of that yeah I thought I feel
like I'm on the fence to be honest
because I feel like everyone should have
the right to have a choice of what they
would like to do with their body however
like what you just explained to me I
don't agree with that because life
um
but what about the baby's trust so what
about the women right baby what about
the women what about the women right in
cultural Traditions who get pregnant and
if they don't get rid of that child
their life's on the line like how would
you justify that they are responsible
but they're also in a lot of danger if
they're gonna die yeah this is what like
this is what people always do with the
abortion arguments they always usually
extremes 99 of abortions are elective
but 99 so it's like you're using the one
percent argument to justify the whole
thing if I said okay give you give you
those abortions in the life of the
mother would you be okay with Banning
the rest
that are from poor decisions true I
understand I do agree with what you're
saying in terms of it being a poor
decision but I still think I still stand
with what I believe I agree
people make silly mistakes all the all
the time but it's not like somebody
that's sticking with them for Life yeah
and you know I know a lot of girls that
don't make the same likes and don't get
pregnant it's not like people make silly
mistakes all the time
if you're irresponsible I also think
like you know you've said about um like
Backstreet abortions and illegal
abortions or whatever I
sure Naturally that that might happen
but I also think it's possible that if
women don't have the option for abortion
but they might be more careful because
can you imagine like if if we were
living like how we all are today
um and like let's say like you go out
clubbing you find someone you have a one
night stand or whatever like I don't
know like contraception because I'm not
feeling like oh my God like if I had to
go in for an abortion like I just think
the fear of that like I think over the
last three years I've certainly gathered
that fear controls people and fear like
instills certain behaviors in people and
I think by not having the option for
abortion generally speaking say 99 of
the time
um I think women would just sort of wise
up we're not silly if you know that it's
going to be difficult to do something
you'd avoid doing anything that would
lead to that being the consequence
that's just what I think it's actually
true I don't agree with abortion I just
believe that people should have a choice
I don't agree with it because I don't
think she however
I do believe that we should have a say
do you think that women should be
limited on how many abortions they can
have oh yeah oh definitely yes
definitely definitely because after that
first time you shouldn't even be wanting
to make stupid mistakes at that again it
should be a lesson do you think men
should ever say an abortion yeah yeah so
do you think if if I got pregnant and I
wanted to abort it and a guy wanted me
to keep it should he ever say yeah yeah
he has to say but you have to come to
like a legal say yeah like both both
parents need to sign off on the abortion
yeah that would be very practical I
think I think that is correct yeah
because she could have the baby and then
like he she might not want it say for
example I understand there's a burden in
carrying a child but we have to be
responsible in a sense mutual agreement
then yeah I get that I think that'll be
hard because it'll be easy to just say I
don't know who the father is
I feel like a lot of people would do
that I feel like a lot of people would
probably say they don't know who the
father but there's ways to find out if
they are the father so if a man wants
the child then I think that's really
unfair to take that away from me no I
really do definitely because when you
become a mom like you're so happy you've
got a baby like for someone to steal
that away from me or like change their
mind three months in and you're so happy
to take that away and you've got no
saying it that's heartbreaking of course
but also I feel like maybe these women
would would I mean would they be
changing their minds because of
something very serious or is it just I
understand that women have the right to
do that but I just think at a certain
point after pregnancy there's you can't
be chopping and changing because yeah
from when you tell your man is you're
pregnant like he's in his element so to
take that away from him he's still in
his dream because it will a lot of us
dream of having a family so I just think
you can't jump and change that it's 50
his DNA why doesn't he get 50 of the
choice I believe he should have 50 of
the choice but then what would happen if
they don't agree
yeah no they have to agree in order for
it to happen yeah so if one is continue
saying nope another saying yes then it
won't happen then it wouldn't happen
yeah okay that's why I was saying they
both have to sign off for in order for
it to be an abortion
um do you guys think that women should
serve jail time if they allow a man to
raise a kid that's not his 100
definitely that is so evil I think it's
so Jamaica we call that Jackie basically
you gave someone a jacket yeah that is
really really yeah it's horrible I
definitely that's a crime definitely
because a man imagine you're raising
that child you create a bond you love
them you give them your all financially
spiritually everything and then to find
out when they're 20. that should be like
a life sentence
for 15 years and then you find that it's
nothing that should definitely be
punishment for that yeah that is
horrible but then on the flip side there
is we're living in a time where guys can
get DNA tests so yeah yeah but if you've
told someone it's their child why are
they going to do it it's illegal in
France to DNA test really oh wow I think
I think it's either they both have to
sign off on it so if the woman doesn't
want him to she can just away that's
insane but that that kind of shows
already if the woman's saying no you're
not yeah no you're not gonna get it some
women do say no because and they know
that is the child is the man there
should be mandatory paternity test I
feel like it should be because then it
will get over the emotional thing of oh
because you're my partner because if
it's happening to everyone it's fine
yeah but I definitely think that they
should serve jail time yeah long
sentence everyone should get a DNA our
DNA tests expensive yeah they're about
you're saying they should be mandatory
no I don't think that should be
mandatory to test to check that the
child's demands no I think it should I
think it's you don't think it should
yeah I think there's so many men that
are afraid to do it one because they
don't want her to freak out and I think
there's a there's a lot of guys that get
trapped in paternity fraud it's a really
common thing especially like in the U.S
yeah I just think from a government
perspective it would avoid a lot of yeah
at all I know avoid having to have the
conversation because it's a protocol for
everyone you know what I mean I wouldn't
do that and I would never cheat on my
partner like but that's what you have I
under somebody else you know someone
somebody else might want to read it I
think it's fair to do that to somebody
like why would you care if the kid's his
yeah I just don't think it's fair I
wouldn't have a DNA test I don't need to
I know that's my man's child I'm
speaking from me I suppose I'm a selfish
perspective but I just don't think that
would be fair
yeah yeah it doesn't feel right it's a
real problem in society if you have to
put that in place yeah
when you think about it there's a lot of
women that probably have done it or even
in a situation right now are actually
doing it the world
even until the man dies they will just
keep that they'll keep that today
there's people that do that so I agree I
agree you should have we live in a
country also like I just want to put
like a really Niche perspective in there
like I mentioned I'm adopted
on the search for your parents if it was
done mandatory at Birth at least you'd
know like yeah true you know because you
you know I know it's such a small
minority of people but like you know you
need to be able to know if you're not
really a minority because a lot of
people must like I think it's only like
2 000 kids a year or adopted I think
there should be an option for it so 30
of paternity tests are negative wow no
way wow that is crazy
societal perspective if it's that common
of an issue that is insane and let's see
we cut it in half because you know
people getting that might be more likely
to do it let's let's cut it in half and
say it's 15 that's still one in ten yeah
that's crazy 1.5 in 10. no that's insane
no that's insane but then if DNA was
actually mandatory that might actually
put fuel to the problem anyway in the
get-go because then females wouldn't
really care about being cautious of okay
if I sleep with him you are the father
don't sleep for anybody okay mandatory
and um the DNA tests I'll just check
who's the father and bum is you just
pick who who's the father that's it so
it would add to them
you'll make their lessons they'll make
them live sex with one person more yeah
because it's like I'm not trying to go
through that thing where I give you the
DNA test you're not the massive kid some
girls don't care about that if they care
about that well I think good girls react
the same but the girls that would do
that would probably be less likely to
try to commit paternity fraud yeah if
they knew they would get caught yeah
when the baby came out then how many
good girls are there we're not facing
them that's why it should be mandatory
yeah
yeah wouldn't you say that's why it
should be mandatory yeah it would add to
the problem if it was mandatory I don't
understand how it can explain that to me
because then females would not take
precaution in who they sleep with in in
terms of it wouldn't really matter
because then their DNA tests will
actually tell them who the father is why
why would they be less they would be
less cautious because there's a DNA test
at Birth yeah because it's mandatory so
it doesn't matter who the father is it
will just tell them who the father is
and that'll be it they can sleep with
multiple guys at the same time you think
women are cautious now
to a degree you just said that there's
no good girl or there's very few good
girls
to a degree they actually are cautious
like they don't sleep with 10 men at the
same time to a degree if you had a
mandatory DNA test then they will sleep
with 10 men in one night and wouldn't
care who the father is no but you would
have to pick the dad and then you'll
give that person a DNA test and then if
he's not the dad you have to find them
then she'd be the problem because she
wouldn't be speaking to a man saying
like it's your child you wouldn't even
know who the child is so there'd be no
afforded in the first case
[Laughter]
yeah we all have to guess maybe you have
to wait till the child comes out and say
who does it look like the moon you
couldn't even do that though she just
wouldn't know who the dad is because
she's been with so many men yeah oh God
and it will be even one side if like she
cheated on her partner obviously and the
partner's there so excited yeah I did a
DNA test boom negative wait did you see
that video or that article where the
baby um it was like two white people the
baby came out black and she accused the
guy of sleeping with a black girl what
oh yeah that was a boring
yeah I was just like what world do we
live crazy
um okay I'm gonna read super cats again
these this woman that is so easily
how does that happen
I I don't know I think some people it's
kind of like liars will die out a lot
yeah yeah it's like you could say Okay
point a of why you're lying point B of
why you're lying in point C of why
you're left but they'll die on it
they'll die on that Hill for whatever
reason they know it makes no sense
um Slender scoot if if women have the
right to choose to be mothers then men
should have the right to choose to be
fathers if you can't even communicate
with your partner you shouldn't risk
having kids Maury
um after seeing photos of abortion
during the late first and early second
trimesters I'm completely against
abortion except in the cases of grape
incest Etc C Dumbledore the only thing
women will fight for is their right to
be irresponsible and maximize their
hypergamy stop by Miriam's um the
morning after is the morning after the
morning after is an abortion pill I
honestly don't understand the mindset
that babies are a burden as a mother who
became a mother at the age of 24 after
college graduation becoming a mother is
so incredibly fulfilling
ht10 ladies do not take birth control
terrible for your health
track your Cycles with the app you won't
you can only get pregnant three to four
days of the month
drop Barracuda a clear difference in how
men and women see each other it can be
seen by Googling misogynistic songs
which re turns expected results but
missandra's miss Sandra's song several
of the results are a playlist of anthems
to be celebrated zuras lost your mother
money success status make you more do
not make you more attractive or high
value you just turned into the men that
you always wanted to marry being a fit
feminine fit
um coachable friendly is what keeps a
man a scout in Bradley most men like
natural looking women for a wife
interracial relationships shout out to
the women in the gray pants for being
high value which means she'll stay loyal
to a man regardless of the money you may
want to be married but you don't know
what it takes in a marriage I'm Zorro
loss if you're not single by if you're
saying you're not single by choice only
celibate there is plenty of good men out
there that would treat you like a queen
it's just the men you want don't want
you it's your job to retain the men
after y'all hook up one baseball fan
curious what curious does a man owning
his
curious does a man owning his own hold
any water for long-term relationship
considerations being financially
responsible in general as well um see
Dumbledore blacks were the most uh were
blacks were the most married race in the
1950s and now they are the least of 19
million black babies
19 million black babies were ended since
Roe versus Wade it's genocide I'm drip
Dolly the loose I'm the issue with
dating now is that women don't want to
build with men anymore they move in my
mom met my dad when he had nothing 20
years later he's a multi-millionaire and
loyal a after her now women expect to
wait at the finish line and demand that
same loyalty on Mike SW I'd love to see
traditional Asian wives on the show
Borman um they keep they kept their
mouth shut in the 50s and accepted the
beauty of the energy exchanges
Housewives and those raising Garden
sorry and those raising the garden and
its fruits um Stoners based talks single
mothers have to find a man right away
for their child or children they need a
man Nicholas Lewis to the man
who suggested men can suss out bad
behavior how does this explain
indoctrination oh I read this one
already I'm gonna refresh it really
quick guys just to see if there's any
more make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification Bell you while you're at it
so you can always see when you're live
when we're live Das token E30 spoiling
your kids is not parenting zero Fallout
one if there was a nationwide paternity
test that was 30 percent would be even
higher Courtney J get your passports
fellas
um Jamaica is the number one in the
world for paternity fraud for my
Jamaican friend big up Pearl you're
doing God's work keep preaching the
gospel
slender scoot if women have the right
okay
that one so
if women have the right to choose to be
mothers do you think men should have the
right to choose to be fought to choose
not to be fathers
sorry sorry if women have the right to
choose not to be mothers do you think
men should have the right to choose not
to be fine I have that choice anyway
agreed here yeah here they have that
choice
okay so do you do you think that's right
yes or no and why
that a man can sign off on his rights
and not pay child support
and not pay child support and the babies
there yeah because they're for girls the
right to get an abortion then shouldn't
he have the right to sign off
do you mean in the circumstances that
says a woman was pregnant and she said
she's keeping it and the guy's saying oh
I don't want the baby do you mean in
that circumstance or you mean in general
like yeah so if um
yeah if if there's a baby and I don't if
I don't want to be a mother I can get an
abortion so he should be able to sign
off on the rights yeah and not have any
kind they'll have to get a contract in
that time where he says I don't want to
be of um the father and you're still
having a child and then I don't think
you should have to pay child support
you're basically saying cool I'm okay
with being a single mom then I think
it's kind of hard to answer that one
because like you said before a woman has
a choice
um to take contraception but so does a
man have a choice to wrap up so he
doesn't get her pregnant so I feel like
you both have a responsibility if you
have an unprotected sex as a man you
know what can happen so
I just think some women they'd get
pregnant like on purpose like to break a
family or whatever so I think in cases
like that she should deal with it and be
responsible at the fact that you've both
done it so he didn't want a kid you know
he didn't want a kid like some women use
it to entrap men so I think she should
deal with it like if it's like that then
he has a right well and we're the only
ones that can consent um and know all of
the circumstances because we know when
we're ovulating and we know if we're on
birth control or not so I mean girls as
she as she was saying I have an IUD yeah
mm-hmm
um what do you guys think yes no
yeah I feel like you know
they both have the responsibility and I
don't know I don't really know how I
feel about that
um
I'll see you like if it's like a
one-night stand
and like certain women their day when I
have a child by whatever they're not
really concerned who their dad is yeah I
think he should be able to have the
freedom to say you know what I'm not
saying it's right here
I'm not saying it's right in the sense
of doing it like the same way of
abortion I think each circumstance is
going to be unique to its own you know
what's interesting we'll call a guy a
deadbeat dad but a girl that has an
abortion isn't a deadbeat mom yeah
I would never call anyone a deadbeat dad
like that so I won't say that because
the child isn't here yet whereas when
the child is here and they expect of Dad
to look at that child and see how
beautiful he is and just want to help I
mean but you'd expect a mom to not want
to kill her child I feel like but people
are visual I realize when a woman's
pregnant well how it depends she doesn't
do it six months you can't see that baby
you can just see a little bump whereas
you can see a little beautiful little
baby sitting before you yeah but you can
get an ultrasound yeah I mean like and
you could feel the baby yeah you can
definitely feel it 100 but I just feel
like
from outside of looking in people will
judge a man more because they think oh
the child is here you're and you're
still not being active I just think as
women we're more judgmental like and
harsh on men in general like I think
women judge men too much and are
ungrateful for certain things and fail
to look at ourselves as women
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible